in a few minutes we're gonna definitely
follow that as well now Vincent with the
white pieces here we go must win
situation for him here we go
uh okay the game has started it's A
variation of the English opening or the
ready depending how you look at it and
uh depends on magnus's next couple of
moves how will he set up
what do we think is he gonna go solid
Magnus or is he gonna play
typically kind of Fighting Chess even
when you need to draw
uh well I think he's going to go solid I
mean he only needs to draw and it's
symmetrical English which is a very
solid opening isn't it generally and
well maybe now he's offering some tarash
France position yeah
um but uh Vincent's gonna have to
perform wonders to win this game isn't
he but he has got the white pieces
um those are the main three options okay
he pushes this Pawn the world number one
but Magnus immediately pushes forward in
the center and yeah we're gonna see this
really tense standoff yeah Magnus maybe
just trying to okay he plays it again
and
um yeah Magnus just maybe playing a game
of cat and mouse here he knows what he
wants to play but he's slightly afraid
that Vincent has prepared it we see a
Trader Pawns in the center
um one move I've played here is to push
this one I was about to say played this
myself once before White's Bishop now
has a nice home and Black Blocks it up
yeah very ambitious play actually from
Magnus despite the fact he needs just
that draw
and now the pawn structure is in Balance
black has more space on the queen side
but white has an extra Central Pawn if
you look at the central two files the
end files danger that Vincent has
Vincent flicking in a check here may be
entering into some slight tactics now
and Vincent I was going to say probably
has to use his pieces the pawn but the
quality of the pieces is not great and
Magnus does eventually Castle yeah I
mean so maybe Vincent just well he's
playing very quickly here I mean maybe
he must have some idea what you said
there David makes a lot of sense because
uh I was reading in a book that like
chimps are actually much better at
certain tasks than us well quite
actually set and asked quite a few tasks
like in memorization spotting patterns
they have five minutes on the clock
three seconds after every move and after
this first Blitz game there will be
another one where Arjun will have the
white pieces you will definitely follow
this as well yeah I mean what do you
guys foresee in the next few moves it's
been going to be able to maybe change
things up turn things around just looks
like that just looks like Vincent's
falling into a very bad opening line
actually which you're aware of I mean it
doesn't seem that obvious to me uh that
it's completely disastrous and while
he's playing all the moves he
recommended and I I can see how things
are going to really get hot around
White's King quite a